YOUR SCREEN.
I HOPE YOU DEMAND TO RELEASE THE
MEMO.
STRATEDGEST SEBASTIAN GORKA AND
SARAH CARTER AND CRAIG JARET.
SARAH, IT WAS LAST YEAR THAT YOU
FIRST SAID, WAIT A MINUTE.
STORY.
EXPLAIN TO MY FRIENDS WHY IT IS
DAY.
>> BECAUSE WE HAD TO HAVE THE
EVIDENCE.
EACH PIECE OF THE PUZZLE IS
ANOTHER PIECE OF EVIDENCE TO
THEY ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
INVESTIGATIONS WE WERE NOT PRIVY
TO BECAUSE WE COULD NOT ACCESS
THE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
HILLARY CLINTON WON, WE WOULD
HAVE NEVER KNOWN THIS WAS
HAPPENING.
THIS IS WHAT THEY EXPECTED TO
HAPPEN.
THIS IS WHY THEY GOT SO LAZY.
WHY WE SEE THE TEXT MESSAGES
BETWEEN PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE.
NOW SEAN, THIS IS REALLY
INTERESTING.
BEFORE I GOT HERE, I WAS
CONTACTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS, FORMER FBI AND
CURRENT.
THEY SAID GET THE TEXT MESSAGES
FROM ANDY MCCABE.
GET HIS TEXT MESSAGES.
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT MORE
WHERE PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE
LEFT OFF, THERE IS A LOT MORE TO
BE SEEN THERE.
ONCE AGAIN, THIS IS ONE PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE AT A TIME.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO DO TO
UNCOVER THE TRUTH.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
BE JUST AS SHOCKED AS CONGRESS
AND THEY WILL GET ANSWERS
SHORTLY.
FOR THE FIREINGS?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
TOP OFFICIALS SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
I SUSPECT THIS INTEL DOCUMENT
WILL REVEAL MULTIPLE FELONIES BY
HIGH RANKING OFFICIALS AND THE
THERE IS A FEDERAL FELONY
STATUTE.
IT'S CALLED DEPRIVATION OF
RIGHTS.
DEPRIVE SOMEBODY OF THEIR
CONSITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
HERE IT'S THE CONSTITUTION RIGHT
TO PRIVACY UPHELD BY THE SUPREME
FEDERAL JUDGE USING A FAKE,
FALSE DOCUMENT TO OBTAIN A
WARRANT TO SPY, THAT'S A
VIOLATION.
THAT'S A FELONY AND 10 YEARS
BEHIND BARS.
PEOPLE OUTTO BE PROSECUTED FOR
THAT.
>> Sean: ANYONE YOU DISAGREE
THAT SHOULD BE FIRED AND AGREE
THAT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER NEEDS TO BE DISBANDED
BECAUSE IT WAS DONE ON FALSE
PRETENSES AND SEEMS ILLEGALLY?
>> ONE OF THE CONGRESSMAN WHO
SAW THIS 4-PAGE DOCUMENT SAID
YESTERDAY PEOPLE OUGHT TO ARE
THE ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
HE IS MUELLER'S BOSS.
>> Sean: DR. GORKA YOU WERE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR PART OF THIS
TIME.
PROBABLY FRUSTRATING TO YOU?
>> WELL, IT WAS.
THE PRESIDENT TOLD ME ONE DAY IN
THE OVAL OFFICE JUST THE TWO OF
US THEY WILL FIND NOTHING
BECAUSE THERE IS NO RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
THE PRESIDENT MUST BE COMMENDED
I HAVE TO REPEAT AND EMPHASIZE
SOMETHING YOU SAID IN YOUR
ICEBERG.
INTELLIGENCE AGAINST U.S.
CITIZENS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT WAS ABOUT FISA.
ABUSING THAT SYSTEM.
THEY COLLECT EVERYTHING.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
FOREIGNERS.
EVERY CALL MADE OVERSEAS.
EVERY EMAIL AND EVERYTHING.
I WANT TO KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
IN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION --
>> Sean: WHO WERE SURVEILED.
ALL OF HAVE YOU BEEN AMAZING.